hot breath well i know you've suffered
from panic attacks a lot so like before
doing
letterman the late night show like were
you just a
bundle of nerves like no i ended up
being okay and that was
sobriety and i kind of got really into a
lot of buddhist stuff and meditating and
all this uh
stuff that i'm always dismissive of
because i feel like people are like ah
screw you yeah you just said buddhist
stuff
yeah yeah i'm always because people are
like
buddhists i'm like no but i read a lot
of books like i got really into and you
have a tick not han quote in your email
yeah which is amazing because that's who
sort of changed my whole
life his uh books i've read about you
know 25 i have one on me at all times
this one
over there i'm sure and that is really
helpful but yeah i definitely was afraid
of
panic attacks because panic disorder is
something that
is inside you it lives in you it doesn't
just go away you just kind of manage it
mm-hmm
so i had a definite fear that i was
going to have a breakdown
and lose my mind on st because i have to
think of like i just picture dave out
there and they're like the guy can't
come out he won't come out and then like
that was in my head but you have to just
let that
go away like don't even let that
manifest itself in you and
i just um like we talked about the hmong
way i just tried to stay in the moment
like i had what helped me
stay calm was like and this helps in
life and it's i think it's good advice
in general
where you're worrying about something
like well i'm not doing it right now
like i'm worried about the set but i'm
like but i'm not
doing the set right now i'm sitting in
my bedroom so i don't have to worry
about it now
and then the car ride over you're like
why don't worry about it now i'm just in
the car
over there and then i'm like i'm putting
on my suit but i don't have to worry
about the set because i'm just putting
my suit on right now
and so i just kind of stayed in each
moment which allowed me to be sort of
relaxed
leading up to it and doing my breathing
exercises and
and then also i got some great advice
from comics where
my friend nate bargetsi uh who's
wonderful
read statenate hilarious yeah uh one of
the best yeah but he was just saying
i was asking people for advice and he
was like you're almost beyond being
nervous at this point he's like you've
been doing it so long it's like it's
five minutes
and my buddy nick griffin is a wonderful
comedian and guy guys i interviewed him
a couple weeks ago
yeah he's a great great great guy a
tremendous comedian but he um
he just said he gave me great advice and
he had the voicemail saved he said my
advice is he's like you don't
need advice from me there's nothing i
can what am i supposed to do
you know you don't need advice you know
you do he's like everyone has great sets
it's a great crowd they're hungry and
it's weird because late night you get
hyped up and but it's really just a
comedy show
and you're doing five minutes it's like
a short
set for a hot crowd so it's like you're
kind of just going all right and then
you have to worry about tv just worry
about the people that are there and
they want you to do well everyone that's
there wants you to do well
and you want to do well everyone
involved wants you to do well except for
the people on the internet but
they're not there at the time youtube
comments yeah exactly
so i was actually pretty calm and
relaxed and it was almost uh bizarre it
was almost like a
weird experience where i was like i
guess i'm gonna do this not particularly
nervous i mean i had
energy going in right i was anxious to
get out there but i didn't feel
nervous i wasn't close to panic or
anything like that i just felt like oh
this is cool and amazing and crazy
i felt really calm maybe not the right
word because you still are on tv so
you're jacked up but i felt
very um at peace it was really great
and you mentioned breathing exercises
yeah could you could you kind of expand
on that a little bit breathing exercises
is a weird
term i guess just just focusing on my
breath it wasn't breathing exercises i'm
not going to make it sound like i was
giving birth
maybe i could learn to learn just kind
of focusing on
uh my breath my in-breath and my out
breath because you're breathing
through all these things it feels like
you're not because you're not
consciously
thinking about it because you're just
kind of in a panic mode and that happens
not even just in
anxious situations but when you're
talking or hanging out that
your body is breathing it's just second
nature or third or fourth nature
whatever the hell nature it is
you're just not conscious of it so it
can be calming to kind of sit and
and kind of feel your like almost
physically feel your breath going
through your
nose and in your diaphragm and lungs and
can kind of almost instantly
calm you down which is the thing that
tiknot han is always sort of talking
about and writing about
and so that really helped to kind of get
away from the noise and just be like
and also that you're at home in your
body even though you're in this crazy
situation your
body is still your home and that's uh
where you are
and it's still just you you know you're
always sort of
home in your own body even if there's
chaos going around
will you do it for like a count like
would you like inhale for seven and
exhale for seven
um not me personally but that's
certainly a thing that people can do i
guess i have
done that at times or but just kind of
just taking a moment to be like
i'm breathing and i'm a human being and
i'm alive and uh
it's definitely helpful okay yeah is
this is this kind of lifestyle something
that replaced the drinking
um yeah in ways i mean i try to be
conscious of it and i don't want to i
mean i'm still
a anxious nervous guy who's
self-conscious and insecure i don't want
you to sound like i don't want to sound
like i'm
you know oh you're doing so good but um
but yeah i try to do it consciously
throughout the day and
uh especially when i get nervous or
anxious and stuff
mm-hmm did you done that your whole life
or just when you found sobriety you
found like an alternative
no just after sobriety i was like i
always i always wanted to be into that i
would do yoga and stuff like that and i
always wanted to kind of be into that
because i've always had anxiety and been
nervous my whole life
from as early as i can remember which is
kind of strange i realized later for
like a four-year-old kid or a
six-year-old to be like
just nervous like ah like panic at like
a family event
so um yeah i kind of went to the
bookstore and uh the first book i got
was a book called
happiness by tic not ha and i was like
oh that seems like something i'd be
i want to be happy and um so i kind of
started reading all those and got really
into that
you just you just had a feeling that
book would be good for you well i went
to like the eastern uh
philosophy you were searching eastern
religion yeah eastern religions or
whatever it is
and um yeah i like saw happiness i'm
like oh that's what i'm
looking for and also i was like tick nah
just seem like
that seems like an asian guy they seem
to know what they're doing over there
and so
i got that one and it was really uh very
applicable and easy to understand and
read
has that mindfulness helped to your
comedy as well
uh i think so i think just being able to
be relaxed and happy more where i'm like
let me get some work done you know i
want to try to um
i think so yeah i think it's all sort of
benefited
all aspects of my life